[Musique]
qu'est-ce que taraf 1 2 puis un triple
un blizzard prend pour un fou
dix mois depuis hier matin je suis
plongé dans un monde parallèle où toute
ma vie a changé
félix je te jure que c'est vrai hier
encore j'étais mariée avec olivia
on était fous amoureux l'un de l'autre
et puis j'écrivais des places et l'orge
à 300 mètres carrés je faisais là la
coupe des magazines j'étais invité au jt
de 20 heures j'avais une [ __ ] de vie
et là je me suis réveillé dans cette
nouvelle vie où ma femme n'est plus ma
femme elle est devenue une des plus
grands pianistes du monde ne me
reconnais plus
prénom c'est refaire c'est fou c'est fou
c'est pour c'est fou
résumons avis aux philippines bong
plutôt bon attends je fais dit que ça va
pas le faire du tout moi ça fait
millions que j'ai pas joué
[Musique]
m
si tu fais comme je vais me tourner le
dos à ce que l'état bits comme ça tu
connais c'est pas ma meilleure amie
mais oui je connais tu habites et tu
préfères bct plan cul dans sa
garçonnière à dire si tu as bien ouais
c'est ce qui ferait plaisir tu présentes
ce message qu'on ne trouve pas annoncé
comme quoi les pieds et oui c'était les
piétons à tafer faut que tu m'aides à
retourner dans ma vie d'avant tennis tu
peux faire ça
striée chabwa qu'est ce que je vais te
regarde son coeur morgane quand j'ai
regardé pour la première fois de ma vie
qui l'avait sorti comme une flèche ça
marche pas je te dis ça ça marche un peu
je le regarde et val à la flèche
bonsoir bonsoir vous saviez que c'était
mes fleurs préférées football quoi marc
tu viens
vous êtes l'agent père agent est presque
mon mari
[Musique]
forcément un truc qu'elle lui qui a
provoqué tout ça
il faut que olivia retomber amoureuse de
moi dans cette vie ici pourquoi je crois
parce que dans l'autre je sais tout je
sais ce qu'elle aime ce qu'elle déteste
ses patins
oliech notamment entrer oui ça fait des
années qu'on scolaire
tant son encontre toi moi on s'est aimés
très fort
on était marié c'est pour ça que je sais
tout de toi
[Musique]
si tu avais été mon mari pendant tout ce
temps c'est dingue
[Musique]